ce
il y à 21 ans jett chan est entré nu
dans ce monde en criant ce soir il va
finir de la même manière au bordel où
est mort fils on a regardé la télé
manger des paninis puis on s'est endormi
père jeff chang va le tuer par un heure
je viens d'avoir une super idée espère
encore on s'en fiche une dernière fête
et aux rentes est sûr que c'est la bonne
adresse fait descendre dans son bas non
l effet des centaines de choix au bordel
qu'est ce qu'on vient tuer jeff chang
jeff chang cette 21e anniversaire
c'est le jour où tu es meilleur ami yvan
sortie 21 ans black jack bauer
aujourd'hui c'est le jour où tu donnes
tu es bien réveiller là je me sens pas
leur bac
7 les bouger d'accord c'est ce patch
ching trang on arrive aux yeux des
choses là et grouille toi tu bouges quoi
il est en train de brouiller
ouais ça je le sais c'est en partie ce
que tu lui as demandé de faire non on
n'a pas encore tout dit elle
tu peux mais ce violeur sud asiatique
alors tu crois qu'on se connaît tous
phrastique de merde
anne on attend elle était mignonne non
ouais mais c'est pas mon genre de fille
c'est quoi son genre celles qui veulent
coucher avec